The Joe Rogan Experience I I mean I
guess because I talk about American con
culture a lot I I come with a degree of
anticipation but it was a torrential
rainstorm in Los Angeles I'm aware that
like you've moved out of there that a
lot of significant people in the space
that I work in have moved out of there
and there was a feeling of uncanniness
and eeriness some of the familiar sites
for homelessness have been cleansed as
if by Travis Bickel's Reign you know
it's sort of like just they've moved
homeless people for example Gower Street
the Gower Street Bridge there would
always be sort of like a little tented
Community there that seems to have been
moved along and maybe a perfect metaphor
for that problem you know moving them
rather than you feel like those homeless
people are still somewhere rather than
that problem has found a resolution no
one really has a tangible resolution I
haven't heard one resolution that's like
okay that we could put our fingers on
that's real do you know that in our
country during the pandemic in London
especially but also in other cities they
temporarily housed homeless people as
one of the pandemic measures like we
can't have people on the streets they'll
cough on someone put them all in hotels
put them in hostels they solved it and
then when they reached the point where
they were happy that the pandemic was
that had leveled out they kicked them
all back out again right that's it we're
not worried anymore get back out there I
wonder why they did that do you think it
was just too much time and effort to
manage those people like they're
shooting up in the hotels and causing
Ruckus and well I wonder what what was
the reason for like putting them back on
this tree because it seemed like if they
solved that like they should be like oh
well you know let's just keep dedicating
these resources to keep these people's
hot housed I feel like that the anomaly
was the housing rather than the the
ejecting I feel like that they when it
was convenient and suitable they could
find a solution to homelessness there
was an economic one and then when it
wasn't necessary anymore they just
pulled the rug out from under it but I'm
sure like yeah that comes with
complexity when I was first working in
media when I was still using drug addict
myself I did these things that I
considered to be like psychological
jackass you know that was a Big Show at
that time those amazing guys doing those
incredible stunts and I was like well
what if you did the psychological
version of that so I had like a boxing
match with my dad I had a homeless guy
move in my house I seduced an
octogenarian lady I uh jerked off a man
in a toilet all of these things were the
periphery of my limits as a drug using
young man just trying to make a way in
my way in media when I had that homeless
guy come live in my house with me James
was his name God Rest his soul like it
was interesting to encounter that you
know there's a reason of course I fully
accept and appreciate that that could
happen to any of us that any of us with
a few wrong choices could end up
destitute and lost without the kind of
support and good fortune I've had in
various areas in my life I'm sure it
could have happened to me of course it
could have but there was a sort of like
a gravity pulling him back out into the
street you know there's a gravity
pulling it was like he couldn't couldn't
deal with being in a house admittedly
these were not organic conditions there
was like a cameras around and stuff it
was not a higher it was not a high
budget production it was really low-fi
stuff on a low-fi digital channel but
being around that guy he was a like a
heroin user I was using heroin with him
at that time the sort of peak of the
show was when I got into we we had a
bath together that was like I thought
what's the most intimate thing you could
do with a person to sort of overcome the
idea that homeless people are somehow
dead you're different or you know like
they should be excluded from society so
I had a bath with this guy this stuff's
still online somewhere I presume and um
you know it sort of it pushed both of us
to our limit in the end James decided
that he preferred homelessness
that's right he made his choices in the
end we just got a taxi to nowhere just
like just got a taxi for him and just
yeah just let him out anyway work his
own way in the world yeah so like uh of
course that that problem of vagrancy and
destitution it's a difficult one to
tackle it makes me think that the
culture is laid upon the planet like all
culture all civilization is laid upon
the planet laid upon Gaia laid upon the
Earth like you know when you have people
on here like Graham Hancock and Randall
Carlson that talk about like the
potential for like these seismic events
and cataclysmic events that have reset
civilization it's a makes you recognize
that all of our reference points other
than biological and cosmological are
cultural reference points and therefore
temporal and so a person living in a
tent in the street is in a sense living
a hunter-gatherer lifestyle in
contemporary America or living a
post-apocalyptic lifestyle in
contemporary America it makes me think
sometimes Joe maybe the apocalypse is
not a forthcoming event maybe the
apocalypse is already happened maybe
we're living in the sort of the already
it's gentle threads are encroaching upon
apparent civilization yeah when you're
in comfortable defined and designed
spaces you feel like everything's okay
the end of the world is impossible and
it just seems like entertainment when
you hear about nuclear treaties being
torn up that it can't actually happen
but of course it can it's so temporal
it's happened forever it's always
happened the people that it happened to
them they never saw it coming either
that's a the way you're saying is very
interesting because I think the
apocalypse is here on Earth it's just
not here like right here in Austin it's
not like right here in the studio but
it's in the Congo yeah like if you go to
a Cobalt mine Congo and you see a 19
year old woman with a baby on her back
mining for Cobalt and inhaling toxic
fumes you're like okay well that's the
that's the apocalypse they have no
electricity they have no clean water
they make very very little money and
they work all day and they work for a
company that puts Cobalt into
Lithium-ion batteries that are in
everyone's smartphone so the height of
our technology is directly connected to
what's essentially slave labor and
that's the apocalypse I mean that might
as well be the apocalypse that might as
well be Mad Max that might it might as
well be I mean it's just as bad it's
just as horrific there's a very
beautiful bit of Investigation I saw
that episode so Darth car yeah it's um
it's a he wrote that what is the Bowl
book called uh Cobalt red yeah it's uh
it's all about uh Cobalt mining in the
Congo in his investigation that he did
into it it's very very it's inspiring
that a person uh is that selfless and
and can make that sort of a commitment
and risk their life and go to a very
dangerous place and expose this because
he he's a real journalist like a real
boots on the ground journalist that
wants to show the world some things that
are being hidden from them because the
people that are making enormous amounts
of money from this that could fix it
don't want to they want to profit off of
it at the exact level they're profiting
off of it now which means you know
paying people a couple cents an hour or
whatever they pay them it's it's
horrific